so we've now seen that the algorithm
that we have this branch and bound
algorithm it is not going to perform
well on noisy datasets and as soon as we
go from 18 amino acid masses to a
hundred and forty-four we're gonna start
to really struggle with using this
algorithm we're not going to give up on
it we just need to kind of figure out if
we can find more information that's in
that spectrum is there something that
the spectrum is telling us that we just
haven't been listening to so our goal
here is to say we've got to get the
number of amino acid masses that we
consider down we've got to reduce these
so we've got to go from 144 would it be
nice to knock that down to 50 or 20 or
even 10 in a great scenario so let's
recall this spectrum that we had this
hypothetical experimental spectrum and
let's just see what we notice about it
this is a great problem solving strategy
where if you're if you're stuck on a on
a solution one one of the most common
things to do is consider a small example
and look and see what that small example
is telling you and see if that maybe
generalizes so here's our small example
it's just gonna be for a peptide of
length 4 and we're gonna say okay well
we can't detect the mass of e it's not
in this experimental spectrum so we're
not going to identify that e is is one
of our letters one of our amino acids
that way but hold on we do detect 257
which is the mass of Q E and we do
detect 128 which is the mass of Q all
right and if you subtract these two
masses you should get the mass of e
right he is what's left over with Q E
and Q so when you subtract them you get
129 so that's good can we find it
anywhere else the answer is yes okay ELN
is another sub peptide of this cyclic
peptide and QE l as is Ln and we notice
that the masses of these two are NV in
the spectrum as well we get 356 minus
227 and that gives us 129 we even get
one more the mass of the entire peptide
is 484 and the mass of Ln Q the sub
peptide that doesn't include
is 355 and when we subtract those we get
129 so 129 is still there right it may
not be in the spectrum but if we start
subtracting masses that are in the
spectrum then we're going to get three
occurrences of 129 this is going to
motivate our definition of what's called
a spectral convolution so the
convolution of a spectrum and it's the
positive difference between every pair
of masses in the spectrum so here is the
same spectrum that we had we represent
the masses along here and along here and
we go through and we subtract every two
pair every pair so we have 227 here is
the mass of L M we don't know it's the
mass of L n but we have 227 and here we
have the mass detected of 370 and when
we subtract them we get 143 and we can
do this for every pair and we form this
table now I've highlighted certain
masses and I'll tell you why I've done
that the reason is we want to ask what
are the most frequent elements between
57 and 200 because remember with E we
picked it up in a number of different
places we pick it up three different
times so we want to ask ourselves what
are the most frequent elements between
57 and 200 and there's a good chance
that's going to give us what the amino
acids should be the five most frequent
elements that I highlighted are 99 113
114 1 28 and 129 and when we convert
those from the integer mass table we see
that that's V Ln Q and E right they
correspond to those letters so if we
take the five most frequent elements
four of them are going to give us the
amino acids of nqe L so this is really
promising on this small example so now
we have the outline of an algorithm
called convolution cyclic peptide
sequencing and the first thing that it's
going to do is to say okay given our
experimental spectrum let's form the
spectral convolution of it then we're
going to look at that spectral
convolution and say what are the most
frequent elements in it and so we may
choose this parameter capital M taking
the M most frequent elements between 57
and 200 so and maybe 50 or 20 and
practice and then we're going to run our
leaderboard algorithm using only those
top M masses that we found between 57
and 200 in the spectra
convolution and we're going to form our
peptides only on those integer masses
the question then is does this algorithm
really work that's the question that we
constantly ask right and so let's
consider spectrum 10 remember when we
expanded our alphabet the leader board
method didn't work for spectrum 10 so
let's see if it works for spectrum 10
now now that we're dealing with the
convolution so the first step is take
the convolution then we pick the 10 most
frequent elements in that convolution
which I'm showing here on the right most
of these are actually standard masses or
correspond to standard amino acids so
145 was non-standard but the other ones
were identified as standard then we run
the algorithm on only these amino acids
so these are the only amino acids that
will be allowed in our peptide and the
winning peptide is tau saying b1 and we
should be happy so it reconstructed the
correct peptide just from taking the 10
most frequent elements in the spectral
convolution so it worked really really
well well then we asked ourselves
okay what about spectrum 25 so what
about this noisier spectrum that none of
our algorithms has been able to
correctly reconstruct Harrison E and b1
from what happens if we apply
convolution psycho peptide sequencing to
that really noisy spectrum and when we
do it it's good news we can reconstruct
hi Cindy won again and so now we can
start the party but I do want to mention
one more thing about practical
considerations and I'll do that in the
next section